So a lot of people write in and ask the difference
between the question "why" and the WHY,
as we talk about it, like start with WHY.
The WHY is a purpose, cause, or belief,
the underlying reason why we are motivated
to do something.
The reason a company exists, the reason why
we're passionate for something.
The question "why" aims to get at and assert
the same thing in a generic sense,
like why do you do something, what's the underlying
reason for that?
That's why I called the WHY, "the WHY."
Another reason why I called the WHY "the WHY"
is because when I would ask people,
"What comes first: vision or mission?"
People would debate it.
There's no standardized definition of vision
or mission.
So people who believe mission came first,
I asked them, "So what's the definition of mission?"
They said, "It's why we get out
of bed in the morning."
People who believed vision comes first would
say," Well, it's why our company exists."
And whether it's brand or purpose, all these
things, everybody gave me the same definition:
why.
So that's why I called it the WHY.